hi i'm william shatner and i'm doing
some
wired auto complete questions
if you don't know what autocomplete is
neither do i
first up
does william shatner yes i do several
times a week does william shatner play
guitar no i don't i just string along
does william shatner write books i'm
writing one right now i've got several
books out there i'm writing we don't
have a title for it we haven't even
presented it yet but we've got like a
half a book and it looks interesting to
me does william shatner
speak another language i grew up in
quebec i used to speak french fairly
well
nada and that's spanish
so i don't remember anything does
william shatner know klingon
no
yeah
well sounds very yiddish to me does
william shatner have a fan club a giant
fan club which you can just look on my
website williamschatter.com i think and
find out it's a huge fan club and we
have all kinds of wonderful things
happening you should join up
it seems i've skipped one and i'm afraid
of it you know why it's very long and
i'm going to do it now
does william shatner get halloween
royalties they mean the mask
they made a death mask of me well they
call it a death man for star trek
because there were all kinds of
appliances going on and instead of
having me there for hours putting on
these rubber things
they had a mask made they put the clay
and everything so they had a mask of me
so somewhere along the line somebody got
a hold of that and then sold it to the
halloween thing and then the movie
halloween
needed a villain and they said go and
said to some go get a mask from the
halloween store the guy chose my mask
that i have nothing to do with my mask
became the villain in halloween and when
i would take my kids out for halloween
they trick or treat and if the infantry
the trick was i'd left my mask and it
would be me
next
what was william shatner's first role
the answer to which is a baby
and i emerged
from the womb
what is william shatner
favorite role you know that baby roll
when i suckled at the breast and i was
full of confidence and security that was
my best role what did william shatner
host well i was the host of several
germs until i had my immune system i've
hosted a lot of shows i don't know what
a time what songs does william shatner
sing william shatner sings on bill which
is going to be released very soon first
one with joe jonas the second one with
brad paisley a couple of weeks later
very soon and then the album in
september it's a great album what is
william shatner doing these days i am
doing a great show on the history
channel called the unexplained then i've
got this album called bill which is
coming out soon
and i'm writing a book
and i'm doing personal appearances and
i'm having birthday parties for
teenagers that are getting ready to go
off to college there's a moment
happening in my life where this lovely
grandchild packing up and going to
college
and there's this division that everybody
knows about and one of the songs on the
album is me leaving home
and crossing a bridge
and a 18 wheeler is coming my way and
i'm gonna die
and it's
all of us who cross bridges all the time
and there's always an 18-wheeler coming
at us and that's one of the songs
next
what is william shatner's
favorite star trek now there's a
question i never thought of before i've
never been asked what is my favorite
episode the great scientist
stephen hawking
i interviewed him
it may have been his last interview but
he also said i've got a question for you
and i'm looking at the at the computer
what is your favorite episode
one of the greatest minds of the 20th
century wanted to know the same thing we
didn't want to know here and i
i said i don't know for god's sakes
stephen
i don't know it's 55 years ago and there
were some that were so good
star trek broke itself down into these
great episodes
maybe half of them were relieved really
terrific and the other half were less
than really terrific but really
interesting ideas so
i don't have a favorite what
stunts did william shatner
do i'd like to say i did all my own
stunts
but insurance companies
don't want you to do any stunts because
you could get hurt and they would have
to pay off you see if you hurt your
little finger and you hurt your little
finger and i heard it doing a stun now i
can't work for another three hours costs
money you don't do
mostly your own stunts except
if you can invigo i'll do i'll i could
do that
so i did a lot of that i could do that
and i did most of my own stunts what has
william shatner directed we had a big
birthday party yesterday
and i
being the elderly grandpa
and father
sat in a chair and directed the party
you should take those dishes over here
that was my best directed oh i directed
movies i directed television i directed
i just directed a lot of things
and i directed people yeah you should
take that road over there traffic
direction is really the best of all what
is william shatner's nickname one of the
songs
in this album bill
is my nickname and how i got it
it's called tuffy
i was named tuffy because i had a fight
every day yeah i had to fight a lot of
people every day so i got the nickname
tuffy
are you ready next is william shatner
really 90.
see the nine what happened is they got
the nine upside down so
yes i'm 90. is william shatner a
vegetarian well
i was for a period of time and i made
the cover of the vegetarian magazine i
don't know whether it still exists or
not probably and i was
but i varied back and forth
amino acids are apparently very valuable
and they're in
meat in any case last night at this
birthday party i had one of those
vegetarian burgers and it was delicious
is william shatner
a horse owner my financial advisor said
to me one day
don't buy anything
that eats while you sleep
and i have
many times is william shatner going to
space well the truth of the matter is
i had negotiations going on to go up in
blue
origin and it was like uh i'm going to
go up in the first vehicle and i'm going
to float in space i went saw the vehicle
here's where you sit and here's what and
you'll float and you'll go and i'm
thinking god maybe i can bring some
artistic meaning to what i'm seeing and
the feeling in front
and then he chose his brother
to go up in space with him
so no it doesn't look like i'm going up
into space as much as i would have liked
to
but what i really wanted to do was to
come back down from space i wanted that
guarantee they couldn't guarantee me
next
finally
how william shatner changed the world
come on i changed my my underwear this
morning that's the only thing i changed
how does william shatner
stay in shape
i do the best i can i hear that you know
you keep saying well as you get older
your metabolism slows down but now i
read an article that doesn't happen so i
don't know i'm doing the best i can with
the little i have
swimming mostly
how did william shatner get the role of
this another tape
captain kirk they called me and they
asked me if i would play captain kirk
and i looked at this film that they had
of star trek and i thought wow that's
neat so i agreed to be captain kirk how
long was william shatner how long was
william what is the next word how long
is william shatner there's no apostrophe
ass
on star trek three years on the series
then a
boatload of movies
those were the questions that were most
popular on the internet my goodness i've
done the best i can i hope you're
satisfied i will
see you soon